[Musique]
j'ai 26 ans, militante des droits de l'homme
du Yémen
bonjour je m'appelle yusra je viens d'
un pays que les gens appelaient un
homme habia
mais ce n'est plus
[Musique]
sous la célébrité de la révolte
[Applaudissements]
université  les étudiants ont décidé de descendre dans la
rue
après les deux révolutions d'
egypte et de tunisie,
ils exigeaient un changement d'une
bonne vie une bonne éducation une bonne
santé une bonne économie peu de temps après
la manifestation a commencé à s'agrandir
plus de villes se sont jointes
et puis nous  eu notre printemps arabe au yémen
j'y suis allé une ou deux fois sans en
parler à ma famille
une de mes profs elle était derrière moi et
elle m'a écouté et puis elle
m'a puni parce que j'ai parlé de
la révolution à l'intérieur de l'école c'était
interdit pour
nous et cela m'a fait me demander pourquoi c'était
interdit, en
particulier pour les filles à l'époque, nous
ne pouvions pas dire ce que nous voulions, alors je
me sentais plein d'espoir
et heureux parce que cette révolution se
produit euh,
je sens qu'il y aura un bon
changement dans notre pays
et le changement s'est produit  en fait mais
ce n'était pas le changement que nous espérions
[Musique]
c'était en mars ils l'appellent après ce
vendredi de la dignité
ça a commencé comme un jour ordinaire rien ne s'est passé
les gens étaient des
gens étaient là dans les rues les
gens se promènent
des tirs ont eu lieu et beaucoup de gens
y meurent
c'était des mois sanglants je me souviens encore à
ce jour
comment les forces d'ali abdullah ont utilisé la
force ultime contre euh des manifestants pacifiques
beaucoup de gens sont morts et c'était
juste pour
demander un avenir meilleur
les partis politiques ont commencé à s'impliquer dans la
révolution
euh ils commencent à contrôler la
révolution et ils l'ont fait ils l'ont
contrôlé ils l'ont volé à la
jeunesse ce n'était plus la révolution de la jeunesse
c'était la révolution politique ce n'était pas euh
désarmé c'était '  t paisible c'était euh ça s'est
avéré être une guerre civile
et ma génération a fait face à une guerre pour la
première fois
mais nous étions très
fiers et personnellement car à l'époque j'avais
16 ans et j'ai
connu toute la corruption de l'
ancien
régime j'étais  fiers de voir qu'enfin les
yéménites ont du courage et
disent
[Musique]
non
tout ça a vraiment changé après 2015.
le vrai monde c'était en 2015 on pensait
qu'en 2011 ok c'est la guerre ce
n'était pas le rôle
homeschools hôpitaux rues  ils
ont tout détruit au Yémen
[Musique]
je ne peux pas oublier que les visages des femmes
pleurent dans les rues et courent pour
trouver un
endroit sûr des enfants beaucoup de gens sont morts
jusqu'à maintenant ils meurent
jusqu'à maintenant ils meurent il y a beaucoup
euh de
crimes de guerre  ce qui se passe au yémen,
les femmes du nord et du sud
sont détenues pour avoir manifesté et
demandé des droits fondamentaux tels que
la nourriture être journaliste est devenu un crime
je fais de mon mieux pour enseigner à ma
fille ici à la maison l'une des
choses les plus que je veux  qu'elle sache que
euh nord sud nord ou sud ou
quoi que ce soit ce n'est pas grave
comme ce que les gens disent et
en fait
j'espère que la prochaine génération
de ma fille
sera plus forte dans 10 ans
les gens se
demandent pourquoi nous avons commencé la
révolution, ce
qui est faux parce que nous sommes encore en train de
révolutionner jusqu'à aujourd'hui, je dirais que
pour notre exemple au
Yémen en tant que femmes que nous avons, il
n'y a jamais eu un jour où nous avons cessé de demander
ou d'exiger ou de travailler pour obtenir
de meilleurs droits
les jeunes font maintenant
un excellent travail euh
ils font beaucoup à partir de rien euh c'est
quelque chose que
j'admire ce dont je suis fier
nous n'avons pas fait de
révolution pour être honnête pas seulement de
révolution
nous travaillons toujours  dur sous différentes
formes pas cet élan de grande révolution
nous devons exiger le changement si c'est
pour un bon endroit pour une
vie meilleure nous devons exiger un
changement ouais nous devons
mettre une révolution bien planifiée
pour nous et pour notre  les enfants
je crois que nous pouvons nous le ferons encore
[Musique]
vous